shocking body camera video shows
deputies arrest a legally blind man
walking back from jury duty with a
walking stick hey what's your name and
date of birth I don't have to give that
unless sir
now yes sir I do it happened on October
31st in Columbia County Florida body
camera video shows deputies interacting
with 61 year old James Hodges who is
carrying a walking stick in his back
pocket according to the video responding
deputies at first believed it was a gun
what is your suspicion it looks like
you're carrying a gun in your back
pocket I'm stopping to make sure you're
carrying it properly you are you ensured
that it's not a firearm no you keep
turning so I can't see it you don't have
to be to me well you're being one to me
video shows Hodges refusing to give out
his name date of birth or ID card he
then calls for the responding deputy's
supervisor no sir I'm doing my job am I
detained yeah you are what's your name
and date of birth it doesn't not matter
yes sir it does do you have a crime
would you like me
right here the supervising Deputy again
asks for Hodge's ID but he refuses
[Music]
[Music]
after that Hodges is handcuffed
that's when Hodges confirms that he is
legally blind and carries the
navigational Aid to help him when
walking he also tells deputies he was
stopped while walking back from jury
duty
yes I am
[Music]
had to walk up here in the dark
what jury duty which was canceled
[Music]
after Hodge's ID card is retrieved the
supervising officer orders he be taken
into custody for resisting an officer
and obstruction all right Mr Hodges was
that that hard
it's going to be I want you naming your
badge now for resistance
okay all right let's go
I want your badge number two sir Hodges
is then placed in the back of a squad
car
you want to pull this out of my back
pocket
here I'll grab your jacket for you too
the Columbia County Sheriff's Office
released a statement saying Sheriff Mark
Hunter is quote troubled by what he has
seen in the video and the matter is
being addressed an administrative
investigation into the incident began on
November 3rd when officials say they
were made aware of the situation the
statement also reads in part quote if
policy violations are sustained at the
conclusion of that investigation
appropriate action will be taken lawn
crime Network reached out to the
Columbia County Sheriff's Office for
additional comment but we're told to
refer to the online statement for the
latest developments in this story and
all things True Crime stay with long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie